we're going to town
a shocking 20-page report has been
completed into sexual relationships at
the LaVerne Police Department some
happening while officers were on duty
and at work doing something while you're
at work I mean for everybody else who
goes to work you know we're held to that
same standard Jerry Howell says he was
in disbelief when first reading the
report and once changes from city
leaders the investigation says mayor
Jason Cole got the first tip about the
relationships this is bad it's like a
stain I guess we requested an interview
with mayor Cole but was told he was not
willing to talk on camera instead he
released a statement saying in part we
will be retraining all of our employees
in the rules regulations and
expectations set forth by City
leadership the wake-up call for Laverne
but also a wake-up call for our Police
Department to take care of themselves
you guys don't know this is a cop who
apparently was running having trains
around on her doing stuff on the job at
the workplace to a service they had to
and not the people she was servicing the
servicers to protect and serve other
cops good Lord
uh it was her that picture didn't age
well
you know what's so funny
a lot of people were talking they're
like bro at least a lot of women like
we're gonna be like yo man like I saw
her pictures and like you know the girl
when they arrest their jobs for they
didn't want to just come out and say
like this girl's like a four okay and
that's fine you can just say just come
out and say that she's not the most
traffic it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter that's not even the point you you
haven't put you on a game about the male
brain if it's present and it's down
we go to town
[Laughter]
Hey listen present and it's now we're
going to town Brown
you have to understand one thing like
hey yes sir we are going for the jackpot
and let me say there was a Zach Cameron
that was happening they drilled the [ __ ]
out of her and I talk about no drill
sergeants well take me to wizard
Sergeant that's kind of wild thing left
right left drill sergeant hey yo I've
heard all kinds of crazy ticks like what
what'd you hear but here's Here's the
the the the real simple take of the
matter
people who are at work male and women
traditionally [ __ ] each other
she was married didn't even matter and
I'm going to tell you a lot of office
romance involve people who are in
relationships in America the truth of
the matter is when men and women work
together there's gonna be some [ __ ]
Shenanigans Shenanigans happening even
if you have an anti-fraternization
policy let me tell you they got the
strictest one in the military and they
[ __ ] in the barracks during basic
training they wasted no time they'll
[ __ ] superiors they'll [ __ ] feariors
they'll [ __ ] the person laterally they
don't care they see a hole they're going
in she sees a rod she jumping on I'm not
saying it's always consensual but in
this case it was so we're not even gonna
talk about the more devious [ __ ] and
good on the police chief for firing them
why ABBA they were just sleeping they
were sleeping together on the job sorry
we ain't paying you so you can get some
cheeks
I'm glad you're getting some cheeks yep
but not but we ain't paying you so you
can guess if you get paid to get some
cheese [ __ ] I want to get paid to get
some cheeks not not on my dollars then
cheeks cost me money
so it better cost you too not not on my
dollars it's four dollars it's my dollar
yeah the only people getting paid to get
some cheeks are only famous mom
and they should
but no they deserve to be fired and the
last thing and I think the most
important thing is the husband stood by
her everyone's going after him he said
this is my wife I will not leave her
apparently they were in some kind of
weird relationship that was open but he
was upset when because he's also a cop
when he found out that his other
patrolmen were patrolling her insides I
get it I'm not mad at it I understand
why you'd be upset you wanted a
relationship to be open you're just like
[ __ ] I didn't want it to be that open
you know what I'm saying listen I left
the door open I didn't want you to open
the windows too [ __ ] you could have a
party I didn't want you to let everybody
in the neighborhood in our home but
that's a lot I understand I understand
why he's upset
him stained I don't understand I'm not
gonna lie but hey
it's none of my business
it's none of my business but you know
what the truth is what's the truth I'm
making in my business yo this dude is a
cup man let's give it a stack no let's
talk that [ __ ] you know what I mean no
no last year was all empathy empathy
this year there's a there's a there's
something that happens when
[ __ ] are wearing uniforms right
uh uniforms are not meant to uh show
anybody as advantage or whatever or not
perhaps the cop feel is predominantly
man that that's in there when you got
like a subpar girl that goes in there in
a uniform if the guys if they're
surrounded by guys winner three in a
uniform gets in there and it's a bunch
of it's a bunch of guys
she becomes like a seven to eight and it
don't matter because I'm going on the
one when people saying that she didn't
look good and everything stuff it didn't
matter even in the uniform and stuff
like that if you look at a place where
it's predominantly man if a girl comes
in and she doesn't she she a girl girl
and these guys day by day they see just
guys and guys and guys they just see a
normal girl that's a three she gonna
become a Seven I'll just make it even
more simple you know what this is what
is it convenience store
I won't filet mignon but if the bodega
open I'm getting a chopped cheese yes
sir
I'm getting the top cheese Hey listen
some of you ladies out there y'all are
convenience stores
why does he keep calling me convenience
store you happen to be open at 2AM when
everything else is closed some of you
guys are convenience stores too what
Steven he doesn't want to know his ears
but he keeps a convenience store that's
you yeah and it's okay it's not even
something shameful
is a bad job
temporary I don't let your business
unless you want to be a Perpetual
convenience store your whole life can
call you during off-peak hours it could
be the store you see come in this
[ __ ] shorts convenience store I'm
just saying it is what it is and that's
what she was that's why they were doing
all kinds of filthy things to her
turning into a spit roast giving cops a
whole new definition of pig let me tell
you they went in on my girl they were
cruel to her but she likes it cool she
likes it nasty she likes it disgusting
they they ask her knock knock hey open
up is the police she opened up yeah yeah
they're arresting all kinds of filthy
criminals turns out this cops are nasty
is one of them all you know to the dude
like at the end of the day it's your
marriage you do whatever you want to but
I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah if you said
some boundaries and someone violates it
that much with that many people and
people that you know and they just doing
that [ __ ] Brazil what are you working on
the same place I'm not saying cheating
has got to be the end-all be all your
relationship that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying there's there's certain forms
of achievement that are just so
egregious if you take it back I look at
you a little bit sus like if she cheat
on you because she having like emotional
connection with somebody like okay maybe
you can work your way back and she [ __ ]
your step brother and get pregnant by
him like Nick yeah you know I mean like
there's levels to everything this is a
wild one she [ __ ] your co-workers not
one but multiple and running trains and
all that stuff after you told her
absolutely not
that that to me speaks to like a whole
level of disrespect and like you ain't
[ __ ] but I mean I don't know what he did
what you mean like he might have done
some nonsense I don't I don't I don't
know I don't have that side of the story
possible but right now this year I'm in
my manuscript uh you know shift
[ __ ]
man can do no wrong I'm tired of these
female we'll take going down they need a
new hero you know shut the [ __ ] up get
the [ __ ] out of here take your [ __ ] pack
your [ __ ] Bro
money [ __ ] out of here yo these 304s and
everything they called them
let me open your back door
back
door
what you're gonna do when they're coming
for you when they come for your white
girl yeah
yeah what are you gonna do when they
come for your white girl shout outs to
these cops I don't even know where this
happened shout out to R Kelly and uh R
Kelly and yeah shout out to R Kelly and
Hunter same girl same girl
yeah you know it's crazy four of them
got fired two of them got suspended
three of them three of them got
suspended was it three I saw three okay
maybe two okay what does that matter
whatever why do you think they got
suspended versus five I have my theory
let me hear yours I don't why did he get
suspended you notice the [ __ ] the ones
got fired you know the black man got
fired I I think I know why why why these
other the one that got suspended I think
I think they were covering up they knew
they were covering up they were actually
they were organizing the trains they
were the train conductors you know what
I mean come on out of the train and ride
it you ready what it is what is I think
they clocked out before they clocked in
which I mean they did that outside of
the
yeah yeah if they did that outside you
just get suspended because the other
[ __ ] the other [ __ ]
they kept their uniforms on yo go to the
interrogation room I got some questions
yay questions government facilities
which made the whole thing egregious
yeah the other ones franchise off are
off yeah I think that was the big
difference yeah my suspicious one yeah
yeah because yeah because they frat
we're not on the force we're not wearing
a uniform yeah but some of these
[ __ ] were wild wild and I also
say this hey I heard you were a wild one
and also this oh this girl she said dude
look let me say this okay I don't even
assign more blame to her than anybody
else you wanna know why because one of
the off the top they're her superiors
you're in a leadership position you
should know better and if you're going
to answer this kind of behavior there's
more burden on you why because you have
more powers and you have more
responsibility oh yeah off the top I
would never assign the same amount of
blame to a [ __ ] private as I would
have Sergeant or whatever rank you want
to tell me above that Captain doesn't
matter right if you're in a leadership
position and you [ __ ] your
subordinates the hammer should come on
you even heavier I'm not saying you
don't make her pay as well because she
was definitely clearly wanting this and
engaging and initiating a lot but
they gotta hold the biggest out that's
what it means to be in those kind of
leadership positions so knowing that a
bunch of these guys and her superiors
all got fired good good you can't have
these kinds of people in this workplace
no
no no sir and uh yeah I think that
pretty much covers most of my ideas when
it came to that story anything else no
all right well let us know what you guys
think in the comments below we want to
hear from you
is he a cuckoo
what I say
I say it bro I didn't say nothing you
let all your homies want to train on
your girl I was agreeing with you you
mad man yeah maybe all his homies all of
them bruh imagine going to work and
finally going backwards dudes like spill
baby battering your girl everybody knows
and then you gotta go back with your
girl home all the time you kiss your
girl you got to stop a cement against
you all right cool yeah
using episode of CSI
bring the forensic
all right
all right run in I'm talking about the
train you know there's gonna be all
kinds of memes what do you mean your
wife don't you mean our wife bro there
is all kinds of means the memes are wild
you want to see them